the European Commission is working
around the clock to help address the
coronavirus crisis we're funding
research we are financing the
development of vaccines we support
companies and people who risk losing
their jobs but sometimes the support
from the European Union is even more
concrete I'm very happy that this
morning we were able to repatriate 290
European citizens who were stranded in
Morocco the plane that brought them home
landed safely in Vienna on board were
Austrians and other US citizens as well
and this morning Austria submitted a
second request for repatriation flight
for EU citizens from Morocco and we will
support it too but EU citizens are not
only stranded outside but also within
Europe and this needs to stop we have
proposed solutions to enable people to
go home now and allow the transport of
goods that are needed across Europe we
have to keep cross-border transport of
supplies flowing in particular that of
medical products throughout Europe there
is a big need for masks protective suits
and other equipment to protect ourselves
from the virus we need in particular to
take care of our health care workers
doctors and nurses but also police and
border guards we work with the industry
to produce more protective equipment and
we work with national governments to buy
this stuff together in addition we are
accelerating research yesterday I spoke
to the managers of an innovative
European research company they work on a
promising technology to develop a
vaccine against the corona virus the
European Union provides them up to 80
million euros and I hope that with this
report we can have a vaccine on the
market perhaps before autumn this could
save lives in Europe and in the rest of
the world too
and tonight I will discuss with the
European heads of state and government
about new measures to support the
economy much remains to be done to fight
this virus we can all contribute for
example you can contribute by staying
home and reducing contact with other
people thank you for your support